- Hi.
My name's Dan Peña and I'm thanking
Evan Carmichael for the
opportunity he's given me
for this cameo, if you will.
Focus!
That's it, focus.
But without money you can't save a thing!
Don't you understand?
We all know nobody can
have ten times our IQ,
well then why in the hell
do people make ten times
more than we do, a thousand
times more than we do?
Why?
How many times do I have to say ...
you had the script.
- Hello Believe Nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all
of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn from author
and business coach, Dan Peña,
and my take on his top ten
rules for success, volume two.
Rule number six is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
You might win a prize as well.
And also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(roaring engine)
(powerful instrumental music)
- Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
simultaneously said one word.
Focus!
That's it, focus.
In the many years that I was
a hundred percent focused,
and I created a lot a
lot of wealth for myself,
I only thought about one
thing and that was it.
I'm not saying that it's
easy, 'cuz if it were easy
that'd be like a QLA shop on
every corner, like Starbucks.
My market is 700 thousand
people out of seven billion,
if you want to be me.
700 thousand out of seven billion.
I don't know what fraction that is,
but it's not a very big one.
That's it.
There's 700 thousand people on the planet
that can commit to the
focus, the laser beam focus,
of the Gates, Trumps, Ellisons, etc.
If you want to create generational wealth,
generational wealth is wealth
that you make in 20-25 years,
'cuz depending on the way you Google it,
a generation is either 20 or 25 years.
We do that and I've taught,
and I did it myself,
how to do it in 4-7 years.
Virtually throwing everything
that you've learned
or read, out the window.
But it's focus, and not that
many people can stay focused.
In fact, that's a gross understatement.
Hardly anybody can stay focused.
- Unless we've built the right foundation,
I mean, the house will be wobbly.
And it'll be ...
You know, we got to build
the right foundation.
And for the most part,
most people in this room
and most people listening on YouTube
have to come to the
realization, as sad as it is,
that you have pissed, you have urinated
here to four up until this morning,
your entire life down a hole.
Very simple.
That's it!
If you want to create massive wealth.
If you just want to be a
happy, slappy, housewife from
Dundee.
Or happy, slappy, bimbo from Toronto,
or a happy slappy guy who goes
to the little league games
in Mesa, Arizona,
then that's okay.
But if you want to create some money,
and money's not everything,
but if you don't think
money can buy happiness
you don't know where to shop.
You can get money and
then go save the world.
save the forest in Brazil.
You make money and go save global warming,
which I don't believe in.
You can save the kids in
Biafra and all that shit,
but without money you can't save a thing.
Don't you understand?
Don't the idiots on
YouTube understand that?
Until you make some shekels,
until you make some coin,
you can't help anybody.
Because if love got the job
done you wouldn't all be up.
- If we have two bank
accounts like I said earlier,
a financial bank account and
an emotional bank account,
and where we all fail, myself
included, is emotionally.
I get afraid, you know.
But it's not what happens to you in life,
it's how you react to what
happens to you in life.
But I just push through.
I'm so used to success now,
not blowing smoke up my own (bleep),
I'm so used to it now,
it's my fact pattern.
Nobody's interested in the
failures I've had last year.
I had tried twenty two
different things that failed.
But I tried two that were big successes.
Nobody's interested in the--
Oh I think I'll try
this, and it didn't work.
I think I'll try this, and it didn't work.
- The system that I've
seen that works which is
very much contrary to the
all the other success guys,
which I don't consider myself,
is the mentorship,
where somebody mentors you.
So you find somebody that
is where you want to be,
and has accomplished all this,
either a man or a woman,
and then you find them
and you come to them
with your dream and your passion.
Assuming the chemistry is right
and it's not always right,
the rest is history.
It's like the Tyson/Cus
D'Amato deal you know.
- Yeah.
- Tyson by accident,
with the greatest respect Mike,
found that guy when he
was 13, 14 years old,
when he was doing all
kinds of ugly things,
nothing similar to myself
but it's the same age.
- Yeah.
- And Cus mentored him and tutored him.
And as that, and you know
Mike will admit I guess,
I don't know I've never
talked to him about it,
when Cus died and all that stuff happened,
he made some poor, some
very poor decisions.
So you got to find that
person and you don't just,
you're not just going to find
them walking down the street,
on the high street I mean,
you have to make a concerted effort
to find somebody that you look up to,
and normally that person is
several years older than you,
but they're successful
in what you want to do.
- If you had to keep track
of seven days a week,
24 hours a day what you do,
you would be shocked,
astounded, overwhelmed,
or as they say in Britain God smacked,
how much time you waste.
And I make them keep track
of every minute of the day.
Every minute of the day.
And its not easy.
Its not easy.
And when you find it out,
I have people that have
come to the seminar
that spend 20 hours a day
walking in the fresh air and meditating.
20 hours a week, excuse me,
not a day. 20 hours a week.
And they don't get anything done,
and they don't feel relaxed.
- What ticks you off?
What really sets you off right now?
- You mean irritates me?
- [Interviewer] Irritates
you, pisses you off, yeah.
- Man's greatest burden
is unfulfilled potential.
Man's greatest burden
is unfulfilled potential
and I say, when I look at the audiences,
and I know that maybe only
1% are going to achieve their potential.
Not fully, I still haven't
fulfilled my potential,
but unfulfilled potential
is mans greatest burden.
And it breaks my heart,
'cuz I know what you kids are capable of.
I know.
I've had kids with 80 IQ to 180 IQ,
that I mentored, that have done big deals.
Actually the 80 IQ did
better than the 180 IQ, okay?
And I know what they're capable of
and I know how 10 million or 100 million,
or whatever the number is, changes lives.
And then all of a sudden,
you believe that you can walk on water.
You believe that you can take
a loaf of bread and feed,
however many was supposed to have fed,
and make water into wine.
And when you believe it, see
the true test of a leader
is when you've trained
other people to be leaders.
It's in you kids, I mean you can do it.
If you want it bad enough
and you stay focused,
and you're willing to
maintain that commitment.
- My dad was a workaholic, he was a cop.
But he was a workaholic.
When he retired from
the LAPD after 28 Years,
he had 700 plus days.
They wrote him a check for it
'cuz he never took a day off.
700 in 28 years.
He never took a day off,
he was always at work.
And so I saw that.
Although, then he went on,
he went with the CIA and he
became a college professor.
But I saw him work hard.
And I aspired to follow
in my dads footsteps,
as far as that was concerned.
I turned 16, which is when you
get a permit to work legally,
and I got a job as a box boy,
which they don't have anymore
where you put groceries in the ladies bags
and you help them out to the car.
The first month that I
worked was August 1961,
when I turned 16.
So my birthdays the 10th, so
I worked 20 days, 21 days.
My paycheck for that, 'cuz I
just happened to look it up,
was $241.00.
So I worked about 240 hours in 20 days.
You got a headache,
you don't want to work?
I'll take your shift.
You want to go to the beach?
I'll take your shift, okay?
So my first month, first 20 days I worked,
I was averaging 10, 12 hours
a day when I'm 16 years old.
I realized,
as Elon Musk recently said,
if you work 80 hours a week
and another guy works
only 40 hours a week,
unless somethings wrong with you,
you're going to get twice as much done.
I discovered that.
- Prayer is great.
Contemplation is great.
But if you don't take
action, action, action,
all the rest is wasted.
And what the kids today have trouble with,
they can know reading a book
to taking action.
And I'm not saying you shouldn't read,
'cuz I've read the classics.
I've read Shakespeare and all that stuff.
But it's not taking action.
Taking action is pulling the trigger,
going out and making something happen,
even if you fail.
- I'm 15 pounds overweight my doctor said.
And he said if you want
to be in perfect health,
which everything else is perfect,
my health, I'm well.
You should lose 15 pounds and I said,
"I'd have to give up
three or four martinis
"and a bottle of wine every night.
"I'm not willing to do that."
I know what it takes and
I'd know what I have to do.
I used to run marathons.
I run the Boston Marathon.
And I know what it took to train,
and I don't run like that
anymore. I StairMaster.
But I mean, we all know
how to lose weight.
We all know how to get physically fit.
We all know how to build our businesses.
I can go to the yellow pages today
and pick out any business
that's in this room
and I can find somebody that's
beating your brains out.
I don't care what you do.
And as some of you've heard me say,
but I'm going to say it
again 'cuz it's important,
for this example again,
we're all have 100 IQ.
For some of you I'm giving you some.
For some I'm taking away some.
We all know nobody can
have 10 times our IQ.
Well then why the hell do
people make 10 times more
than we do?
A thousand times more than we do?
Why?
Because they think and
dream bigger than we do.
High-performance people
have high expectations,
not average expectations.
- Matthew and I were discussing
some of the things that,
about why you discounted
on the subconscious level,
some of the things that
have happened because
absence of evidence is
not evidence of absence.
And he said something very profound.
For an Australian this is
heavy duty (jumbled audio).
But he said, "I decided to do
it even though it was stupid,
"I decided to do it."
Stupid meaning,
to follow the process
to an intellectually smart
guy who's an engineer.
And see you won't.
You see, you'll figure out a better way.
And he followed the
stupid process that works
and has been working for 45 years.
20 some years before, when I was doing it,
in 22 years since I've been
coaching, and he called it.
He wasn't trying to be
insulting or anything,
he says, "I just decided
to follow it." You know?
How did you say it?
- Instead of trying to be smart,
I would just try to be stupid.
Shut that part off of
my brain and just do it.
- And what happens?
He did it.
And that's why
it's hard for the YouTubers
and all the others,
because you can't dumb, you know,
dumb down.
You will not believe that its easy.
You can't, you know, you won't.
But he put it very distinctly.
He just dumbed down and shut
off that part of his brain
and just followed the steps.
You don't need case studies.
You have a ...
You have a template.
You have a script,
that a (jumbled audio) monkey can read.
Yet Alex wants a case study,
'cuz he wants to know the shit behind it,
'cuz he's stupid.
And that's why he's (jumbled audio) poor.
You don't need any (jumbled
audio) case studies.
How many (jumbled audio)
times do I have to say?
You have the (jumbled audio) script.
I said, "Don't change a (jumbled
audio) word on the script."
Not a comma.
If it's got misspelled
(jumbled audio) words,
send it out misspelled.
The last thing you (jumbled audio) need
is a (jumbled audio) case study.
This is why you're (jumbled audio) poor.
This is why (jumbled audio) watching this
on YouTube are so (jumbled audio) poor.
- Hi.
My names Dan Peña and I'm thanking
Evan Carmichael for the
opportunities he's giving me
for this cameo, if you will.
Most people know that I'm
a bad boy, barrio bad boy,
that made good who's now the
layered of Guthrie Castle.
That's pretty much a given now.
But when I was starting out, that wasn't.
And most of you know that I
went to a school, a university,
that I had to explain about
because it wasn't a famous university.
And some of you may or may not know,
that I flunked out of
university three times,
and that I was arrested five times
for alcohol related mischief.
And some of the mischief was very serious.
But I am from the barrio
of east Los Angeles,
in my adolescent years.
But I had a alpha-male role model dad
that was a strict
disciplinarian and was a veteran
of the second world
war and the Korean War.
Discipline, focus and commitment
are the three bedrocks
of all high-performance.
I'm also known as the
50 Billion Dollar Man.
Why am I known as the
50 Billion Dollar Man?
'cuz with kids just like you,
I've created over $50 billion since 1993
in value and equity.
One item that is really
lost on most people,
is all my products free.
I give it all away free.
Why do I give it all away free?
Because I want to take a last
excuse to you kids might have
for not trying or for giving up.
Another things that's
often not recognized,
in addition to me giving
all my product away free,
is that 99.999% of all the kids
that have benefited from QLA
in the last 24 years,
I've never met.
I wouldn't know them if they came in
and slapped me in the face.
All my stuff to create
wealth is on my site free,
through my podcast, my
newsletters, etc etc.
So use it, free.
And I wish you all the best of luck
into your Quantum leap and
in life and in business.
Thank you.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
cliotrophy230 asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Charles Botensten.
Charles thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and making
that awesome review
on your YouTube channel.
I really appreciate the support man
and I'm so glad you enjoyed my book.
- Going to be reviewing
his book, Evan Carmichael.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- High-performance
is anything but easy
and staying on top is even
harder than getting to the top.
I've been on the top of my game,
arguably, for three and a half decades.
I haven't had to work in 35 years.
People ask me how do I
get up in the morning.
I get up fired up.
I'm fired up.
I've been high on life since 1974.
Then I thought about it,
and actually since I got out
of OCS 50 years ago today.
But failure is not an option.
And I do fail.
But when I do fail, I am
so (jumbled audio) up.
I can't believe it.
It must be an error.
There must be a typo,
because I'm so used to winning.
- Being a high-performance person
is not possible for everybody.
You have a quote that says that.
- Absolutely.
- And so going to your seminar
and you are not for everybody,
what kind of person are you
and is being a
high-performance person for?
Who does that suit?
- Okay, well
we're talking about my
definition of high-performance,
not somebody else's.
Okay, if you're willing ...
there's a hip hop guy speaker.
I can't think of his name now.
He's been on London Real.
The hip hop preacher.
Well, whoever he is,
he said, "If you don't want
success more than you want air,
"to breathe, don't come to me."
- Is that how you feel?
- [Dan] Yes.
Because if you've got the desire
and you're willing to make the sacrifices,
I've done a $400 million deal with a guy
who dropped out of school at 14.
Who has 1-0 levels,
you don't know what that means,
but in European terms that means
he passed only one course
when he left school,
carpentry.
And we did one of the
biggest healthcare deals
in the history of Britain.
- Motivation gets you going,
good habits keep you going.
Jim Ryun, the great miler,
who never won a gold medal in the Olympics
for the 1500 meter,
told me about 40 years
ago, "Habits get you"
or "Motivation starts
you, but good habits"
but it's like training.
If I didn't train as much as I did,
I'm 70 years old,
I wouldn't look like I look.
And I don't feel 70,
people tell me I don't look 70.
And I can normally work people,
a lot younger than me,
into the ground.
But I've been doing it
for almost 50 years now.
- Yeah, non-stop. Just keeping it going.
- [Dan] Non-stop.